are you eating a bird are you eating a
sandwich I don't know WTF chopped cheese
can you put it in a sentence for me
[Music]
first glance kind of thing I'm assuming
it's just like a selection of chops and
cheeses but that sounds like way too
easy right I'm guessing it's a sandwich
since we're always talking about delis
now I'm from Texas we don't have that
what's onset are you into the bud egg I
said who is she a person either by I
love me a good pressed sandwich because
when I was little you suppress my
sandwiches together anyway so I love
that you do that one man I'm excited to
know what this come tastes like cheers
Cheers
a few grilled onions sweet onions in
there chopped up with your own beef so
homestyle over burgers the mayonnaise
and tomato add a little tang to it which
is really good this is like a circus in
this piece oh wait is that ketchup
this would go so well the fries very
minimal mess maybe like Philly
cheesesteaks and we like cheeseburgers
you will like the chopped chief why did
I do this myself
why'd I wait so long I would give it a
hard seven out of six warm up catch me
can three of this for our breakfast
lunch and hmm I would 100% buy this on
my next bodega venture if I ever am in
Harlem this is probably my first stop
chop cheese at bodega at bodegas I love
bodega
I enjoyed this even though one had
ketchup on it which i think is a really
glowing recommendation I feel like I
underestimated the power that a bodega
Capac that's what far as food and so I'm
gonna give them a chance and go New York
I know every wonderful Digga I know the
story cat manager
[Music]